I, whoa, where am I?
I don't know, that's awkward.
Oh, there I am.
Oh, man, maybe not a white shirt.
Give me a sec.
Let me, let me change shirts real quick.
I realize, maybe, maybe not a white shirt.
So, I just gotta change my shirt color.
Gotta change shirts real quick, guys.
Gotta change my shirt.
Alright, I'm here for real.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Today, we are gonna be here.
We're gonna be here to check out Mecha Break.
Yes, it is.
It's launch time.
It's launch day for Mecha Break.
Because the servers are basically starting, like, started like three minutes ago.
So, yes, we're gonna be going in blind.
I've heard a lot about this game.
I've heard a lot about Mecha Break.
I remember seeing a lot of trailers for it.
We love giant robots.
You love giant robots.
Real throwback.
But yes, it is the official launch date for Mecha Break.
So, for those who don't know, I'm actually sponsored right now.
So, huge shout out and thank you to amazing CSUN Games for sponsoring the stream.
And... I was actually planning on playing this game anyway.
So, thank you!
Now I get paid to play the game that I was originally going to play anyway.
So, yippee!
Thanks, devs!
Anyway, for those who don't know, it is...
free to play.
So, you can actually download the game right now.
If you click on the link that's pinned in chat or exclamation point Mecha, you can actually download the game right now because it is free to play.
For those who don't know what this game is about, it is a third-person shooter and it has three different modes.
So, there is a hero shooter mode.
So, it's a 6v6 hero shooter mode.
There is 3v3 deathmatch and there is called Mashmack.
So, it's basically... there is also an extraction...
extraction shooter in there.
So, there's three different game modes.
If you can download it right now, maybe you'll get into my lobby, you know?
So, there's apparently 15 mechs you can choose and they're called Strikers and each of them have like...
because it is a hero shooter.
They each have their unique, you know, there's like unique like roles there.
There's like Brawler, which I assume is Tank, Sniper for DPS, and Support for, you know, being a support.
I don't even remember I'm sponsored.
I can't... I can't say the other word.
Apparently, it's a very, very fast game.
I didn't get a chance to try out the beta.
So, like I said, this is my first time trying this game out.
And I'm going in blind, basically.
For those who don't know, because I am sponsored by Mecha Break, I do have Twitch drops.
So, yes, let me pull it out right now.
By watching... Whoa, that's a big picture.
By watching this stream, you can have... Oh, whoa.
You can have... Whoa.
Sorry, let me... You can be basically a Mecha Catgirl, I assume?
DragonField, thank you for the tier one subs.
Thank you, thank you.
So, yes, because I am one of the people sponsored to stream Mecha Break at the moment, I am eligible for Twitch drops.
So, watching this stream will grant you Twitch drops.
So, I don't remember exactly how many hours you have to watch.
But I will be streaming at least two hours today.
So, it will build towards the counter of getting these accessories for free.
So, like I said, you should again, two amazing season games for the sponsor.
I really appreciate it for, you know, inviting me to check out your game.
It seems really fun.
I heard a lot of people talk a lot of stuff about this game.
So, I'm super excited to try it out.
But yes, it is free to play, guys.
We love free stuff.
And it is free to play.
Alright, let me boot up that game.
I love giant robots.
Chicks love giant robots.
You love giant robots.
It just reminded me of that.
It actually reminded me of that song when it was...
Woo!
Free!
I love free stuff!
Yippee!
And apparently, you can like...
It's like apparently incredibly fast too.
So, it's very fast-paced.
Which I like.
I like fast-paced shooters in general.
So, I'm looking forward to that.
We dig giant robots.
You dig...
I'm sorry, that sounds like heavily stuck in my head right now.
But those who are wondering why I'm like...
Uh...
Why...
Wait, is this like...
Okay, I don't know if this is the right one.
Okay, usually it's compiling shaders at that point.
Okay, let me...
I guess I close this.
And then...
I gotta make sure I have the right thing on.
Bum, bum.
Okay, I'm compiling shaders.
Ooh.
Is it...
Window?
Is it window capture?
Or...
Can it be game capture?
Okay, we'll find out.
I'm gonna find out if we can window capture or game capture this.
Um...
It's a shooter, but it has fighting game elements.
Melee has...
Ooh!
Ooh, that's interesting.
Um...
I can't wait to try out all...
I'm gonna try out all the classes.
Cause there's like what?
15 distinct classes to choose from?
That's a lot of like different types to like play around with.
So that's gonna be really fun.
Um...
I'm just waiting.
It's compiling shaders right now.
I don't know if I can game capture this.
Let me try window capture just in case.
Uh...
Mecha break.
Okay, yeah.
I think I can...
Okay, I'm window capturing this.
Yeah, I have to window capture this.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay, here we go.
Uh...
No, there's three game modes.
There's the hero shooter mode.
There's the 6v6 hero shooter.
There's the...
Uh...
3v3 deathmatch.
And then there's the extraction mode called mesh mac.
So, um...
That one is the extraction game mode.
So it's basically, you know, pick your...
Pick your flavor.
You know?
Uh...
Boy, thank you for the 200 bitties.
Thank you.
James, thank you for the 100 bitties.
The walking animation really emphasized on...
But the male characters have no cake.
Poor guys.
Also, for those who don't know, Mecha break is now available on Steam, Xbox series, and Windows PC via the Xbox app.
And there's gonna be like...
Uh...
There's gonna be more...
It's gonna come up on more platforms.
But right now, you can obviously try it right now on Xbox and Steam.
And like I said, it is free to play!
Yippee!
Yeah, free to play!
Yay!
And I think there's like...
On day one...
Oh yeah!
Uh...
Almost forgot to mention...
For the first day, there's 12 free strikers.
So you can pick from 12 different characters for free on the first day.
So...
Yay!
Lunchtime!
I've seen so many trailers about this game.
My game crashed.
Okay.
I love the...
Love the timing of that.
That was...
That was good timing.
I was like...
Yippee!
Okay.
So this...
Wait.
Give me a sec.
I gotta make sure...
Discard.
I gotta make sure it's on the right one.
Okay.
It is.
Alright.
Nice.
I have...
Don't tell them I...
I didn't read the rules.
Don't tell them that.
Hello.
Welcome to Shadow.
Mecha Break will officially launch worldwide.
What?
That's right now!
That's...
Today!
11 minutes ago!
Oh, whoa.
It's loud.
Oh, it's loud.
Okay.
Oh, hello.
Mecha Break.
Alright.
Guys, don't snitch on me, alright?
Please enter your code name.
I swear to God.
Someone already took DokiBird.
I swear to...
I swear to fucking God.
Oh shit.
Thank God.
Okay.
I was gonna say.
I swear to God.
Is someone already...
I literally just got here.
I was gonna...
Identify Life is not a joke, guys.
Okay.
I gotta change the skin.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
We'll do that.
Oh, wait.
There's more edits?
Oh my God!
Sorry.
We're gonna be here for a bit.
No.
If I'm too smooth, it looks like I have too much oil.
Oh my God.
We get to have so much customization.
Ooh.
She fine.
Well, this is the real game right now.
Oh no.
They can't do this to me.
They can't...
I'm gonna be stuck here for so long.
Alright.
Face shape.
Whoa.
Okay.
Come on.
Come on, girl.
Okay.
I need to see your face shape.
I need to figure out what shape I want you to be.
Uh...
I mean, can I actually make myself...
Oh my God.
No.
Don't do this.
No!
Don't do this to me!
Guys, I can't.
I can't.
We're gonna use up the entire two hours.
Two hours later.
Okay.
Alright.
What do I want my eye shape to be like?
Ooh.
Let's make her eye...
Let's do...
Oh my God.
It's a little...
Too big.
I was gonna say it so I could see better.
I can't edit the colors.
Oh my God.
Eyelid.
Upper eyelid.
Lower eyelid.
Brow eyelid.
No.
Oh my God.
It's so tempting.
You don't understand.
Okay.
I think the lips are a little too big though.
I'm not...
I don't like that.
Oh my God.
Okay.
We're gonna fix the lips a little bit.
It's a little too big for my taste.
Okay.
There you go.
Alright.
I know she looks very normal.
Okay.
Fuck.
What am I doing?
Why am I making her so normal?
Why is she...
Oh.
Wait.
That's me.
Okay.
Wait.
I can't help it.
I just want her to look pretty.
Haha.
I just...
I just want her to...
I want her to look nice.
I'm gonna be...
Okay, I just want her to look nice!
Hahaha.
Okay.
Ohh.
Let's do that.
And then...
Iris.
Okay.
Okay, we'll just make me...
Oh, but she looks so uncanny with green eyes.
Nice.
She looks so... Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's cat eyes too.
Okay, she looks really uncanny with green eyes.
Okay.
Oh my god, there's lip makeup too.
Oh, that's cute.
Oh, that is so cute.
Okay.
And I realized we're gonna be in a mech anyway.
So...
Omni, thank you for the 150s.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
The worst part is that... I'm gonna be in a mech anyway.
So... I'm not gonna see her.
I'm not even gonna see her.
Wait, okay.
Nice.
Alright.
That's the worst part.
I want her to look cute.
Okay, let's see.
I just want her to be cute.
Dude, is that too much to ask for?
I... There we go.
Um... Oh, I should make it more of... Okay, no.
I don't think they have, like, my yellow.
To be fair.
I'm... Oh, wait.
Unless I put it more... Okay, there you go.
Alright.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright.
There.
Yeah.
God... Exactly.
God be fabulous.
While... While... Ooh, I can do... Do the length.
Ooh, okay.
We're gonna have to fix that hair color.
I'm sorry.
I have to do this.
Okay.
And then... Okay.
We don't want... What's the hair?
Hair color.
Yeah.
Okay.
There you go.
That's more normal.
Alright.
There you go.
We're fine.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
That's good.
Alright.
Body.
Okay.
Guys.
No comment.
No.
Stop.
No comment.
I'm not taking any questions.
I'm...
No interviews.
I once read in a book... You gotta get used to... Kill your sympathy.
So your only power gets things, sadly.
Oh my... Trash doesn't clean itself.
The world is far from peaceful.
Did someone say it?
I hope the love and passion...
Okay.
I like this one.
Wait.
Can we view it?
I can't...
Be... I wanna be this.
No!
To partake!
Oh!
Okay.
No.
You're right.
Delta.
I all...
I thought she was gonna say that too.
Delta.
I legitimately thought she was gonna say that.
Alright.
Bro.
I wanna be this too!
Can I...
It doesn't let me...
I can only apply it!
I can only view it!
How do I be too?
Okay.
Let's try...
Special landing force!
Combat ready!
Alright.
Uh...
Rookie mode.
Okay.
We need to do rookie because I don't...
I feel like we gotta learn.
Alright.
Wait.
Actually...
Are we done?
Yeah.
We're done.
Alright.
Rookie mode.
Standard.
Optional.
Marshmint.
I guess this is the...
Wait.
What's the difference between standard and optional?
Uh...
Oh, better...
What is between like...
Optional and the standard?
Oh, I should...
Oh, mods.
Mods.
Is my mod...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Is my sound guy here?
Sorry.
I forgot to do it.
Uh...
Sound...
Sound people.
Oh, yeah.
There you go.
There's sound people.
Okay.
Bring the game up a little bit.
Nice.
All right.
Give me a sec.
Let me do that real quick.
Uh...
Bring the game up a little...
Okay.
Bring the game up a little bit.
Um...
Standard is the full tutorial?
Okay.
We'll just do standard then.
Wait.
No, I can't do standard.
Okay.
We have to do option.
Never mind.
I can only do option though, I think.
Oh, wait.
Or maybe...
Oh, no.
Oh, it's already applied.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Let me know if this sounds better.
Oh, that's me.
Guys.
Guess which one's the main character?
Guess which one is it?
Also, mods.
If you can like add the drops...
If you can add...
Oh, wait.
Edit my mecha...
Mecha command.
And then...
Oh, still a bit quiet.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll fix it.
Oh, I can't fix it yet.
Wait until I land on Earth.
Then I can fix it.
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
I live.
Whoa.
I know where all the oxygen is going.
Oh, my God.
Are they okay?
You think they're okay?
Oh, silly.
Them sleeping in space.
Come on, guys.
Get up.
Silly.
Silly, guys.
Come on.
Stop sleeping in space.
They'll be okay.
Silly fight.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Oh, I forgot to do one.
All right.
Yeah.
What a bunch of slackers.
All right.
Let me...
I knew...
Okay.
144 hurt.
144 frames.
All right.
And then...
You know what?
Fuck it.
It's fine.
We might be under attack, but they'll be okay.
Oh, wait.
There's no timer.
We should be fine.
Guys, we're fine.
There's no timer.
Okay.
Wait.
Where's the sensitivity, though?
Okay.
There's the T switch.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
I need to turn it down.
General sensitivity.
I wonder if there's like a...
It's okay.
This is more important, guys.
Guys, I'm going to check.
Actually, I'm going to check if there's a sense converter yet.
There might be, actually.
Let me double check.
It might...
Oh, my God.
There's already a...
Nice.
There's already a sense converter for mecha break.
That's good.
All right.
Guys, do you guys remember what my sense was?
Because I don't.
Okay.
It is 0.
I assume my sense was...
I think my sense is 1.8.
So, it should be 0.4 then.
Yeah.
0.4.
Oh, there you go.
1.8.
There you go.
Thank you, guys.
You know what?
That's actually convenient.
Okay.
Nice.
Thanks, guys.
Yippee!
Oh, my God!
Kumbi, thank you for the 6...
Nice.
Thank you for the 69 subs.
Thank you.
I really...
Thank you so much.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
Okay.
Let me make sure the audio...
Bring up just a little bit more.
Okay.
All right.
There you go.
Okay.
Let's try it.
Nice.
Thank you.
Thank you again!
I really appreciate it.
Woo!
Shift and boost.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
You can tell it's super fast-paced for that.
All right.
Nice.
Hello!
Oh, my God.
That's a giant robot.
That's a giant mecha right there.
All right.
Space is jump.
And then air boost.
Oh, okay.
So, I can fly while jumping.
Okay.
Is there, like, a...
There is energy.
So, my right-hand side is the energy.
Okay.
How do I...
Oh, my God.
I was gonna say, where is my gun?
Okay.
Left-click is the sword comp...
Oh.
Okay.
That's...
This is...
Right-click is melee.
Okay.
I get it.
Right-click is melee.
Yeah.
It's super fast.
I can tell, like, it's a super fast game.
Okay.
So, I can hold...
Oh, my God.
This is so fast.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
I'm gonna get absolutely destroyed.
In multiplayer.
Okay.
No.
I'm definitely gonna get destroyed.
In multiplayer.
Like...
Okay.
Now it's self-destruct.
See?
I told you guys.
I'm fine.
I don't have to worry about self-destruct.
I feel like...
I feel like I'm gonna get destroyed.
It's gonna be so fast.
Oh, my God.
Which one's...
Okay.
That's me.
Neutralize.
Enemy.
Left-click.
Energy.
Move.
Camera.
Oh.
I can, like, zoom in and out.
Okay.
Woo!
Sorry.
That was my bad.
That's fine.
Okay.
So, I can, like, move it back and forth.
That was my bad.
I...
I literally walked into it.
So, I have to hold it.
Okay.
I'm fine.
I'm so healthy.
Okay.
Get down from there.
Only I can be in space.
Ba-bum-bum.
Oh, my God.
Where do I go?
Ha-ha-ha-ha.
Run!
He...
How do
I...
Okay.
Ba-bum.
Like, he owns space.
Okay.
So, I'm charging it fully up.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, he'll eventually die.
Wait, no, I just got this mech!
What do you mean?
Full W?
Am I... Am I doing it?
Oh, I am.
I couldn't tell.
It was still so fast.
Wait, three?
What's this?
Oh!
Oh my god!
I just got, like, more armor!
What's going on?
I feel like I was, like, just brought out of here.
Out of retirement, you're like, we need you back from retirement!
And I'm like, where am I?
Okay, get him out of here.
I don't like that my right click is just a shield, though.
I'm not here to defend.
Ooh!
Hello.
See that shield?
Oh my god, wait.
Okay, give me a sec.
Don't worry, I'm charging it up.
You can't- you'll die eventually.
Oh my god.
I'm curious how, like, the heroes- the different classes play.
Okay.
Like, what class this is.
Okay, I need to, like, charge this up.
And just, like, keep charging infinitely.
Phew!
Oh, I can swap weapons?
Oh!
And bypass enemy fluid armor and cause significant damage.
Oh, I got the halberd!
Okay, I like that more.
What the fuck?
I like- Okay, not gonna lie.
That shit is much- that shit is cooler.
Oh!
What?
What did I do?
I did not even- I don't- What did I do?
What?
What happened?
Okay.
I'm gonna use- I like the melee more.
I think the melee is more fun.
That's me.
I bring peace by killing.
Yeah, I think the melee is- Is fucking sick.
Not gonna lie.
I'll get those bastards.
That's right!
Ooh!
Can't find me!
Cause I- Okay, I need super high sense for this game.
Honestly.
I think this game requires insane sense.
Okay, nice.
Ooh!
That's right!
What you gonna do now?
Boom!
Yeah, I definitely need high sense for this game because of how fast-paced this is.
That's right!
Oh, wait.
Am I hurt?
No.
Oh!
This is tutorial!
I'll never be hurt!
They won't let me die!
I'm tutorialing!
Yeah, I'm gonna turn up my sense.
I- I cannot play this with no sense.
Alright.
How much shield do I get?
That's right!
You can't kill me!
Ha ha ha!
Look at my HP!
It's forever full!
Wait, I don't even need a dodge.
What the heck?
What the fuck?
Let me just- I actually- Ha ha ha!
That's right- Oh, never mind.
Here.
Let me just stand in front of you.
I don't- That's right!
My HP is full forever!
Okay, let me put the sensitivity super high.
I can't.
I cannot- Whoa.
I cannot play this game with low sense.
That's good to know, though.
That's good to know that this game requires high sense.
Oh, yeah.
When there's, like, a hundred effects going on.
Yeah!
I'm literally playing on, like, cinematic mode.
Wait, I have- Oh, my God.
That was my armor.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I should have dodged.
Take this thing down.
Okay.
Oh, hey.
There's my friends.
Hurricane and, uh, Lumaine.
That thing that just entered the atmosphere.
Is it friendly?
I don't know.
It's fighting back.
I wonder if it's friendly.
Ha ha ha ha!
He's fighting back!
Friend?
Ha ha ha ha!
Maybe friend.
Who knows?
Oh, my- Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Okay.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Is it fr- It looks pretty friendly.
Ha ha ha!
Wait!
Wait, guys!
Guys!
What the- What the fuck?!
I'm- Okay, that's cool.
That's fine.
We can- Let's just- You know, you could have put this, like, right here on me, you know?
instead of, like- Wading in the- Hah ha!
Wading in the shield.
Like- Okay.
Nice.
Okay, I'll use my cannons again.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Don't worry.
Missile Time!
Pew, pew, pew!
Hi-Ea designer's thinking.
Look!
There're so many things going on, you think I heard getting the bubbles?!
Oh my god, why is he shooting me?
Okay, get in there.
Get in there.
Bistil him!
Yes!
Okay.
Oh, I dodged it, I think.
I think I dodged it.
Yeah!
Wait, did I do it?
Oh, I did it.
Oh my god, there's all of us.
We're a team.
Okay, let's go.
Oh my god, I did that.
I did that.
Smile.
Oh, that shit is cool.
I feel like I'm watching an episode right now.
I'm watching an anime episode right now.
Wait, I want to be the winged one.
Wait, two years later?
It's my birthday!
Two years later!
Happy birthday to me!
Attention, Shadow Special Task Force.
Rescue operation at Moshmok is about to begin.
All relevant personnel complete your final checks.
Weapon airdrop ready.
Cargo rocket ready.
Striker systems calibrated.
No error found.
Combatants, prepare to deploy.
Elise Ness, ready to strike.
Pilot in position.
Striker entering launch tunnel.
Brake system safety disengaged.
Oh, Valia!
Thank you for the Twitch Proud!
Thank you!
That's me!
Oh, she's cute!
For this mission, name's Anka Bell.
Just joined Shadow.
Still settling in, but looks like we're diving straight into missions.
So let's do it!
Pilot, for this mission, we'll locate the three patrol strikers we lost communications with in Moshmok.
Yeah, thank you for the Twitch Proud!
Thank you!
At an abandoned base to the southwest.
Recently, a massive amount of Thea's forces have been active in the area.
This is a rescue mission, so try to avoid going toe-to-toe.
Now, our CO will fill you in with the details.
Greetings, Pilot.
I'm your commanding officer.
My name is Christian.
Hi, Christian!
We're leading this operation.
First, we'll drop you off just outside Moshmok's waters.
You'll travel by submarine.
From there, use the underwater elevator to reach the abandoned base.
Your squad will meet you at the entrance.
Wait, what- what happened in between the two ears?
I'm so- I'm a bit confused.
Ready for anything.
Close combat, long range, and solid defense.
Why did we time skip?
We won't let your striker go in naked like your last atmospheric entry.
Injecting colexium particles.
Wait, what happened?
I thought- I thought- Sorry, I got, like, a planked out for, like, ten seconds.
But, uh-
I, like, keep forgetting what I made.
I keep- I forgot what I looked like.
Oh, shit!
Like, I came from the ocean?
Oh, I like that.
I like that detail.
Let's get going!
Alright, let's go.
Why does my- Oh, my mecha looks better than- Oh!
Oh my god, okay.
Well, I almost dropped down.
Confirmed the extraction point ASAP.
Alright, nice.
Yeah, we skipped the filler episode.
This is where the UWC built their mass driver.
After the orbital elevator attack, the UWC disbanded, and the base was abandoned.
We'll conduct our search here.
What a waste of resources.
Last SAT update shows strikers engaged in combat in the area.
Wazoo!
Do you have a guard?
Not sure.
They've been public enemy number one for the last two years.
They were lunar civilians who fought their government for equal rights.
But now, they've resorted to pure va- HQ!
Do you copy?
Hello, is anyone live in here?
Looks like it was just shot down.
That's what you get for trying to get equal rights.
For mechas.
That's right!
Some mechas were built to be grunts!
Alright, let's see.
Some mechs were meant to be grunts!
Okay.
Just like these mechs.
Oh, I forgot to kill this guy.
What happened here?
Why is Thea rallying here?
Okay, I wanna go melee.
I think melee is a lot faster.
Yeah, melee is definitely a lot faster.
That's right!
Incoming!
Watch out!
Find an exit route!
I'll hold him off!
Oh!
Shit!
Okay!
That's bad.
I can still kill him.
That's right!
You think you're better than me?!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Yes it does!
Oh!
Oh no it doesn't!
No it doesn't!
No
it doesn't!
My bad!
I won't need a run!
I'm no coward!
That's right!
Pew pew pew pew pew pew!
Pew pew pew pew pew!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
This guy actually...
This guy fucks.
Oh no!
My energy!
My poor energy!
It's fine!
It- It's so fine!
That's right!
It's so fine!
Get out of here!
I don't need shit!
I'm strong!
That's enough!
Clue what we've been through!
Oh?
What happened?
Oh!
It's a...
What is that?
He's turning...
He's returning to rock!
Corite doesn't spread this quickly!
You're not hearing this?
Maggots?
Phase 1 is done.
Don't drag this out.
Become a hero!
Oh my god!
All he wants to do is to be a hero!
Haha!
You're not better than me!
Hahaha!
That's right!
Oh shit!
Okay, I gotta shift out.
Oh!
Exterminate!
Oh my god!
Okay!
That's fine!
I have missile!
Get out of here!
You're so low!
That's right!
I'll take it all!
I believe in the ta- Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
No, no, no!
Okay, wait, I can't be too greedy!
Nevermind!
Maybe I don't take it all!
That's okay!
It's okay!
I need your coordinates!
I did it!
Oh!
I regen!
Let's go!
That's right!
Haha!
Hey!
The Earth people should take over this area again!
Deploy the extraction beacon!
What are you waiting for?
Now?
I don't need shields!
This is our only chance before the storm swallows this area!
Now the airdrop can finally reach us!
Oh!
Repair striker!
Now we're pretty tight on time!
Ah!
Let's freshen up before joining the fight!
Okay, I was like, whoa!
Where am I repairing?
Haha!
I was like, did I do it?
Did I repair it?
Haha!
Now, press the interact key to select an airdrop!
Okay!
Oh!
So I can summon weapons!
Okay!
Now- Now I know!
Now- Okay!
Let me see if I- Let's lower the- Okay!
I don't think we need cinematic anymore, guys!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
I don't- I don't think we need cinematic anymore!
I didn't even know we had motion blur on!
Alright!
Let's put all of this at high, at least!
Okay!
Uh...
Apply!
There we go!
I didn't even notice- Um...
I didn't even notice that there was motion blur.
It was not noticeable for me, to be fair.
Destroy as many extractors as you can before the ship arrives.
Oh, this is the extraction bone!
Which triggers pulse storms.
They might deploy more, to keep you from leaving!
Yeah!
I couldn't tell!
Nice!
Okay!
One pulse storm will wipe out everything on the island!
And the three factions are mining and researching Koray at MoshMosh.
Is it some kind of power-play by Theon?
To have their insane demands met?
And fight the moon?
But, uh, maybe it's not that simple.
Did you see all those crystals everywhere?
Yeah, I think I was- I was definitely moving so fast that I didn't notice, for sure.
Cause it was not noticeable at all to me about the motion blur.
Did I destroy it yet?
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say, how is it not destroyed?
Okay, nice.
Now we gotta destroy this.
So I guess this is the MeshMack mode?
I assume?
You can't hit me if I'm in the sky!
That's goddamn right!
Haha!
What you gonna do here when I'm in the goddamn sky?
I don't have energy left.
That's what you're gonna do.
That-
This is Earth's land!
Get out of here, aliens!
We need the resources!
I know what happened in Avatar!
We won, right?
We won, right, guys?
I don't think there's new war extractors.
HQ has pinpointed the extraction area.
Alright, nice.
Let's go again.
Oh shit, I forgot!
Haha!
Okay, we wait.
We wait.
I almost- I almost like- Oh wait, who's that?
Alright.
It's okay.
I'll stay in the air, because I don't think they can hit me up here.
It's fine.
Yay!
We did it!
Storms are expanding?
I don't even remember my energy level.
Not- How much energy?
Okay.
I'm trying to figure out how much energy I- I use up there.
At least there's no fall damage.
Oh, my teammates are dying!
Oh, I was supposed to hit that guy!
Don't worry, I got you teammate!
Pew pew pew!
Pew!
No need to thank me!
New coil, alright.
Oh, wait.
Oh, this guy.
I was gonna say, new what?
Pew pew pew pew!
Okay, he's dead.
Yay!
I'm a hero!
Oh, my God!
There's so many people!
There's more?!
How many are- Why do there's so many people want to kill me?
I'm just a nice guy.
I don't commit that much murder.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
There's another ship.
Okay, that's fine.
I get closer to them.
I'm glad my teammates are being meat shields right now.
Yay!
I did it!
Thank you to my team for being good meat shields.
Goodbye, team!
Oh, my God.
Who's shooting me?
Who is shooting me?
I can't de- Oh, my God.
I can't deploy.
I can't deploy because they're all shooting me.
Okay, that's fine.
My teammates got this.
Oh, my God.
Who is it?
Who is it?!
Get out of here!
Okay.
Okay, now I can.
It's fine.
I can't!
When they shoot you, it interrupts at me.
So, I can't- I have to, like, kill them before I can do it.
Goddamn p-shooters.
They just want you to stay.
They're like, we missed you.
Okay, the shield sort of looks badass, though.
Okay, not gonna lie.
It may or- It sort of does look a little badass.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
I did the- So, that was the MASHMACK tutorial.
Oh, that's interesting.
Yeah, so it's, like, basically, like, an extraction shooter.
That's me!
Our main character material.
I thought we would still have at least a hundred years to figure a way out of our demise after the catastrophe.
But now that we're seeing how fast Korite spreads, that estimate might, in fact, be closer to 30 years, or perhaps even less than that.
Oh, that's, like, the- the virus type deal.
to the catastrophe, due to the emergence of Korite.
I saw a chance for us to unite, to rebuild our homes.
I had high hopes that Korite could spur growth in technology, and offer a path to human survival.
But ironically, we've put everything we know into this striker behind me.
That's me!
That's my striker!
All it changes is how we fight each other.
Another way to quench our thirst for blood.
Yeah, but are we winning?
Everybody wants a better life.
Fertile land.
Breathable air.
So we keep scrabbling over what's left of Earth's resources.
And during a recent operation in MASHMACK, one of our brave pilots discovered that...
Korite...
is conscious.
Oh, yeah!
Because he took over...
that Mecha.
We're not sure if it's a sentient being in a different form.
Was it like a hive mind?
But it's spreading...
much faster than we expected.
As you might already know, Shadow was founded to resolve conflicts...
It's like...
mechs...
humans versus...
the environment.
Because we're like destroying the Earth...
and like battling over resources...
so they're like...
STOP!
GET OUT OF THIS PLANET!
Humanity can't get its act together.
It's on us to bridge the gap between humanity and Korite.
MASHMACK's ground zero for Korite disasters.
And a battleground for extremist factions.
It's our job to stop these lunatics from losing Korite...
Or I'll stop your life.
...pulluming the circus...
...and wiping out humanity.
And even if Korite proves to be sentient...
...which it may...
...we still need to find a way to survive.
Let's buy humanity some more time.
Yay!
So we can destroy the Earth more!
Let's go!
Hey Christian, can I talk to you real quick?
That voice from the last battle...
I don't think that it came from the pilot.
Interesting.
We're looking into the combat data and...
The combat data?
No, that's not it.
I'm talking about something completely different.
I've got a bad feeling...
Guys, I'm listening to the plot right now.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
No comment.
I'm not taking any interviews.
Evolving into Silicon-based life forms.
That sounds like something you might see in an old sci-fi movie.
If that's the case...
We're literally living our sci-fi movie!
Get some rest.
I'll keep you guys updated.
This is sci-fi!
What you talking about, Christian?
Wait, I can take a...
I can take a photo?
Wait, what does that look like?
Official preset?
Aw!
Aw, that's cute!
Okay.
Aw, I can...
Aw, I can position her, too!
Aw, my God!
Wait!
Okay, this is so detailed.
What does this do?
I can take a photo.
Ha, ha, ha!
Ha, ha!
Dead drop tap.
Poom!
Oh, that is...
That is a lot.
That is actually...
Alright.
Take photo.
Yay!
Ha, ha!
In America!
Let's go!
I don't wanna...
I don't think I should share this.
I...
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
Oh, I can't, like, have different... Oh my god, I can't even see her.
Oh, I have different fingers, too?
Oh, that's cute.
That's actually cute.
Alright.
Is she okay?
I think so.
Let's see what she looks like right now.
Yeah, she's okay.
Alright.
We will not save.
Alright, nice.
We'll return.
Oh, that's cute.
We get to take photos.
Where did I not go?
Oh my god, look at that robot go!
Dance, robot!
Dance!
Okay, return to my room for the next... What's this?
Terminal?
Oh!
Wait, is this... Oh!
Oh, okay.
That's, like, the lobby.
Oh, so it's, like, an interactive lobby.
Oh, that's... That's cool.
Okay, I like that.
It's definitely a lot more immersive, too.
Also, by the way, you guys want to check out Mechabrick right now?
You can... It's actually free right now.
And you can click on my link pinned in chat or exclamation point Mechabrick.
Uh, and you can check out the... Uh, you can check it out yourself as well.
Oh, I like how it's, like, super immersive, too, for the lobby.
Whoa!
New mission received.
All relevant personnel proceed to the tactical station.
Oh, all right.
Okay, we got new orders, guys.
Remember to check... Wait.
Oh, wait!
They're speaking Chinese!
Oh, my God.
CTV 13.
All right.
Let me, uh, go here.
Head to the tactical station.
Hello, everybody!
Things aren't looking good, Chief.
Core rights everywhere.
Resources are running low.
At this point, wars are unavoidable.
More than anything, this is a test of morals.
Why don't we just work together to defeat the Core's?
Right, but I'm not in my breath on that.
The world leaders are not going to talk this one out.
The three factions and the moon are openly at each other's throats.
The world's in shambles.
Pair that with the chaos and moshmok and the borders.
Our hands are already pretty full.
Besides, our pilots need different strikers for various combat situations.
And what about the pilots?
No, I didn't play the test for it.
This is my first time playing it.
We're short on pilots at the moment.
So that means we're counting on you for this mission.
Mizra Matrix will send five striker pilots alongside our squad for this operation.
You know how it is.
Strategy and striker pairings are key in co-op missions.
Oh, there's co-op missions?
Confirm your striker with Alessio.
Get prepped and move out as soon as the mission's live.
We just rolled out a new brake striker.
Come on.
I'll show you.
You'll love it.
No, it's a...
It's a third-person shooter.
So...
Oh, okay.
Now we're at...
Reporting.
Visit Ace Recruitment to purchase and deploy Leone, Pirova, and Lock...
Okay, so now we can check out all the other...
Oh, Christian's Challenge.
Okay.
And then you can follow them and everything.
Yay!
Oh, that's all my uniforms.
Oh, Daily Sign-ins.
Okay.
Oh, that uniform's cute.
That's actually pretty cute.
That's a pretty cute uniform.
But I think I like my current outfit right now.
Um...
I like my current outfit at the moment.
Wait, why is...
Oh, is this like the current...
Okay, so these are...
I assume...
Okay, these are all the strikers you can be.
So there's...
Medium Attacker.
Light Attacker.
Ultra Heavy.
This is a tank.
I assume...
Brother is the...
Melee.
Oh!
Narukami!
Light Sniper.
Okay, what about Heavy Sniper?
I actually wanna try...
I wanna try...
Akira.
Oh, that looks sick.
Airborne Kit.
Mobile Beam Cannon.
B, B, C, C.
Okay.
Oh...
I like that.
Actually, I like the...
How they...
Wait, actually, what does it look like when I...
Swap to...
Okay, what about Medium Support?
What does that look like?
Is that the one with the wings?
Oh, she has a little drone!
Oh, a little repair drone!
Rapid...
Oh, I can grapple!
I like that.
I like how it does, like, a little, like, introduction.
And you can skip it, too.
So you don't have to, like, look at it for too long.
Okay, that's cute.
But I wanna try...
Oh, there's...
I wanna try the...
What do I wanna try?
I wanna try...
Yeah, I wanna try Akira.
Oh, so I just unlocked these.
So they're all free for now.
Yeah.
All of these are, like, free.
So you just click on it.
And then you don't have to look at the intro again.
I wanna look...
But, like, I hope...
I really like the intro.
So I hope, like, you can, like, replay it.
Too.
Okay.
What's Tactical Station?
Yeah, the intro cutscene looks so badass.
I like that.
What's that?
Oh, okay.
First squad to complete the objective wins.
Oh, so these are, like...
Oh!
These are the different...
Uh...
This is a...
This is a deathmatch.
So this is a 6v6 hero shooter.
This one is the deathmatch.
Um...
Under...
Is Operation Storm the mash-mack?
Okay.
Operation Storm is the extraction.
So...
Um...
So we wanna do Extraction Shooter.
This is the Extraction Shooter mode.
And then this one is the 6v6 versus 3v3.
First squad to achieve 8 kills.
And then...
What's the marketplace?
Oh, that's for skins and stuff.
Okay.
That's interesting.
And then...
Oh!
The first one!
So, like...
You see the Striker Bay?
I just noticed.
The Striker Bay...
Oh, and then you can swap weapons?
Charge Rifle...
Oh...
Oh, it tells you what I have.
You know what?
I can...
Is there training grounds?
I wonder if there's training grounds for this.
That's a...
Yeah, there's a lot.
Uh...
That's matchmaking.
Is it training grounds, chat?
There's a training mode?
Where is that?
Pilots...
There's me.
Is it Striker Design?
Oh, no.
I can edit.
Oh, I can...
Oh, my God.
I can actually...
Oh, no.
Don't give me all that power.
No.
That's too much power.
Oh, there it is.
There's training.
Okay.
I want to see the ability...
Don't...
That's too much power.
Hey.
Guys, I can't.
We got a...
I can't.
You know I'm gonna lose so much time...
Doing that.
Guys, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I just want to know what the Sniper is like.
Oh, so it actually is sniping.
Okay.
Oh, it is.
And then what's my other weapon?
What is my other weapon, though?
Okay.
Mobility kit.
Wait.
I'm fly.
I can fly.
Mobility kit deactivated.
Oh, so that's my...
Oh, so I can fly.
What's this?
What am I doing?
Oh, I have...
I can hover too?
Oh.
So I can literally fly like this.
What's the...
What's three?
What does three do?
Mobility kit deactivated.
Okay.
I'm going to do the...
Weapons overview.
Alright.
Sniper mode.
Pulse claw.
One.
Airborne kit.
Three.
Oh!
So I have a lock-on mode.
Wait.
What does one do?
Target required.
Oh, I need to set targets up.
How do I set up?
Hmm.
Uh...
Training settings.
Okay.
Select striker.
Uh...
We'll put...
Alright.
Where is he?
I need to use you.
Oh, shit!
Ha ha!
Okay.
That's cool.
Oh.
Oh!
It's aimbot!
It's literally aimbot!
Alright.
Nice.
I did...
I did play the tutorial.
I'm just trying different characters right now.
So I'm ha...
I'm trying this...
The heavy sniper.
So I...
The three is just literally...
Uh...
Three is just like aimbot.
Because it...
Wait.
Is there...
Headshots?
No.
It's not.
Oh!
Wait!
There's no headshots!
I can literally just...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I don't have to shoot it.
It like auto-ing.
Auto-aims.
Nice!
There's no headshots.
I'm pretty sure.
It's just auto-aim.
Okay.
Yeah.
It just auto-aims for me.
As long as...
Oh!
I'm pretty sure there's no headshots.
Right?
It just hits.
Yeah.
And I don't have...
I don't have a melee.
So that's like the only issue.
Like I'm literally just sniping.
Execute.
No.
Let me execute.
No!
It's too late!
All right.
Okay.
I think I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm so good at this training thing.
All right.
It's time to...
Oh, there is headshot damage multiplier.
He...
I don't feel it.
I don't know if I do need...
I'm so ready.
All right.
I'm going to be the wit...
I'm going to be the...
The sniper in the 6v6.
And people are going to hate me.
But that's okay.
I...
People are going to be mad.
That's me.
All right.
Heavy defender.
Heavy...
Literally.
We guys...
We have no support, guys.
Guys, guys.
We may...
Guys, we don't have a support, guys.
Guys, are we fucked?
We don't have a support.
We don't need support.
It's over.
Thank you for the hundred videos.
Thank you.
Guys, I think we're missing something, guys.
GG's.
No heals.
It's okay.
We don't need support, guys.
If we kill all of them...
We can just win.
Exactly.
Just kill them first.
All right.
We're waiting.
What are we waiting for?
Approach.
Oh, dismantle it.
Okay.
So we have to be the first to dismantle the most.
That's me.
Okay.
Guys, they don't look like they have support either, right?
I can't tell.
I don't know what they're playing.
Okay, guys.
We just gotta make sure we don't accidentally press T.
What is he doing?
He's just a play.
Oh, my God.
Is he hitting me?
Oh, it's because I'm leaving the combat zone.
Whoops.
Give me a sec.
Oh, my God.
This is just an air fight.
I'm gaming.
Guys, I told you we don't...
We don't need support.
Look at us go.
I have no idea where anybody is.
I...
That's right.
What's going on?
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
Oh.
There we go.
Oh, I'm gaming.
Oh, this is so easy.
Where am I?
Oh, shit.
Whoa.
I'm flying.
That's it.
Auto aim.
Oh, my God.
He wants to kill me so bad.
He does not like me.
You're so bad, bro.
Bro.
Oh, my God.
He's one.
You're so mad.
You're so mad, dude.
Oh, wait.
I need energy.
I don't have energy anymore.
Guys, I need...
I'm not doing objective.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I think we might lose because none of us are doing objective.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
That's fine.
Do we do it?
Are we...
I don't know if we're winning.
Let him out.
Don't get him to me.
Don't get him.
I'm very empty.
Please.
I'm just sniping.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
He's so fast.
He's actually so fast.
Oh, I hit him.
I hit him.
Nice.
Double kill.
Oh, we have to go to the extractor.
It's okay.
Okay.
This is so easy.
Wait.
This is so easy, but, man.
Did we do that?
I think we did.
Oh, we are definitely winning.
Bro, we're...
These guys are actually so bad.
Poor guy.
Okay, we got to get to this one.
That's right.
Get sniped.
Oh, my God.
I keep...
I keep accidentally...
Okay.
Did I snagged him?
Nice.
Poor guys.
They're pretty bad.
This has to...
No, there's...
Yeah, no.
They're not.
They can't be real.
I cannot believe they're real.
I'll be...
No, the...
The enemy team has 281 ping.
There's no way.
I think they're real.
They're...
It actually has their ping in everything.
Wait.
I think they're real because they have ping.
I just think they're real because of the ping.
Okay.
I think it...
Yeah, I got him.
Nice.
Okay.
I got to make sure I don't...
Whoa!
What?
Just a sniper.
The sky is ours.
Oh, my God.
I'm so low.
They actually aim for the sniper.
They're actually...
No!
Oh!
He actually...
He actually hit the sniper.
You freak!
He got that freak.
Oh, they had enough.
No way.
I can't believe it.
He actually...
That went for me.
Those freaks.
Did we win?
Yay!
We won.
I lost it too, Billy.
GG.
Wait.
There's no way.
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait.
Am I...
Did I get...
Oh, I'm MVP!
Yeah, that's right!
Oh!
Look at me go!
Victory!
Oh, easy.
Oh, that's me again!
Oh, yeah.
Watch this.
That's right.
Let's go.
Oh, and it's more...
Sorry.
I have the longest play of the game ever.
Because every game is play of the game.
Every...
Oh, my God.
Look at that.
Wait.
Not MVP?
But...
But everything looks so cool.
I'm not MVP!
It ain't something to mess with.
Oh.
But I'm so many...
I thought he was looking at this.
I was like, look!
I'm MVP!
That's the end.
I was just panning.
But guys, look at me, guys.
Oh, my God.
It looks so cool.
I was just panning myself.
I was like this...
It's like the podium thing where you see like second place and stuff like first, second, and third place.
And I'm like the guy on the second place freaking out.
And be like, oh, my God.
I did it, guys.
Okay.
Let's check.
I bet you they're real.
They have to be real.
Okay.
0.1.
To be fair, the game just came out.
So I can't even tell.
I can't tell if they're real or not.
Because the game literally just came out.
So everybody has 0.1 hours.
Okay.
Next.
I can't believe it.
We got robbed.
I mean, I did a lot, though.
Yeah, the game just came out an hour ago.
Oh, I got so many badges.
Nice.
Got coins.
Oh, I'm making it.
I'm getting there.
Actually, I like the hero mode.
Alright.
Let's try...
I like my character.
I don't...
I mean, the good thing is that you can try out different...
Okay.
Let's try the...
Let's try...
Okay.
There's heavy...
Is there medium sniper?
Okay.
I want to try...
Let's see.
Oh.
Oh my god.
It's so hard to choose.
They all look so good.
Valerius, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Hi, tier.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Ah.
Okay.
The guy who played Panther...
When he, like, grappled to me was, like, scary.
He turned...
Oh, I shot that guy who turned into a turret.
Bifrost Industry.
Oh.
Okay.
I assume that guy...
I assume he, like...
Um.
I assume...
He's, like, medium brawler.
So, I assume he...
Uh.
He's, like, dive.
Right?
Because his name is Panther.
Alright.
Let's see.
Uh.
The light sniper's a lot of fun.
Alright.
I'm done with you.
I want to snipe.
I don't want to play with you anymore.
Someone was, like, light sniper's pretty fun.
I was, like, bet?
Oh, my God.
It's, like...
She's, like, a centaur type deal.
The backs here.
It looks like an extra leg.
I love all the mechs design.
The mecha designs are pretty cool.
Not gonna lie.
Okay.
This one has camo?
Oh, they'll never know.
Alright.
Let's see...
Let's see what she does.
Um...
I want to go to training and see what she does.
Yo!
Why is this mech high?
Alright.
Let's see.
Um...
Wait, no.
F2?
Okay.
There's sniper mode.
Charge beam cannon.
Fires plasma in defect.
Okay.
Deploys stationary drone to generate a mask that decays that coordinates with the striker.
Dealing minor damage and putting the striker into stealth mode when within range.
Stealth is disabled.
Auto recalls when up to two droids.
Uh...
Useable drone immobile.
Okay.
That's...
So this is my stealth thing.
And tactical.
Cancel stagger and fires the grappler to pull the striker and enter stealth.
Pulling a locked target causes the striker to leap over and stagger it.
Finding a vertical terrain lets the striker hang on to it.
Stealth is disabled.
And then optical camel drone deploys a station that puts all allies within range into stealth.
Stealth is...
Okay.
So three is my stealth mode.
So this is...
What's the range though?
How do I...
How do I use it?
What?
Oh!
Okay.
So I'm like a little...
Oh!
I'm like a spider!
Okay.
I get it.
And I can have two of my drones with me.
Okay.
So they basically attack for me.
Alright.
Let's...
Let's grab someone here.
Optical camo activated.
Okay.
And then...
Optical camo deactivated.
How far is my range for this?
The range is not that far.
Which I've noticed.
Yeah.
This is like a...
This is like a spider.
Okay.
And then...
I can deploy a drone here with me.
What's the cooldown for my shield?
Did I use it?
Okay.
I did.
Oh!
So like...
I can do like...
Triple snipers.
Basically.
Okay.
I get it.
So I can do like...
Something like...
This.
And then...
And then have like...
Three hits.
Type deal.
Okay.
I can charge it?
Oh!
Nice.
Okay.
That's good to know.
And then...
I wanna try...
I think the grapple is like...
Pretty short though.
Okay.
I wanna try grappling him.
So apparently I can stagger him.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I might...
I happen to have a higher sense for that.
Alright.
I get it now.
Okay.
I need a really high sense for...
To like do like...
To like 180 that.
So that's the issue.
Alright.
Let's try this.
Uh...
Alright.
Let's try 3v3.
See how that goes.
Let's see how...
How much I'm gonna get shit on right now.
Hahaha.
I don't know.
To be fair.
I honestly just wanna try the...
The hero shooter.
And the...
Um...
And the deathmash.
Uh...
I'm not...
For me personally.
I'm not an extraction shooter player.
So like for me.
I think after trying that once on tutorial.
That was like enough for me.
IMO.
Just cause I'm not an extraction shooter.
Uh...
I...
I'm not like a huge fan of extraction shooters.
Like I'm fine with...
I like...
I like the hero shooter mode.
And also the, uh, and also the, uh, well, I haven't tried deathmatch yet, but I do like the hero shooter mode.
I'll do one more extraction shooter just to see...
Uh...
Q sniped where- oh, I was like, what?
Alright.
If you're a big fan, please support and pocket me.
If you're a fan, please support right now.
And pocket me.
That's right.
Come on!
Swap!
Uh...
Liar.
A fucking liar.
Not big enough, exactly.
Not big enough fan, apparently.
Liar.
Pocket the squishy, invisible sniper.
Guys, if you pocket me, I will- I'll be a tanky sniper.
No, you can't swap.
There is a swap button.
They're lying.
I saw- you can like press cancel and swap characters.
They tried to lie to me.
I saw the cancel button.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, not gonna lie.
Why does this robot look like- A little high.
How do we do 3v3?
Destroy all enemy units and claim victory.
Okay.
Wow!
Oh my god.
Where is he?
I'm scared.
Okay, nice.
I'm helping.
I'm helping?
Oh, I'm- I'm helping.
Ha ha!
That's right!
Okay.
I'm gaming.
I'm scared though.
Oh.
Oh wait, they're- Ha ha ha ha!
Okay.
Okay, we need our- get our drone.
That's stupid!
That's fine.
Oh shit, it's not fine.
Everybody's playing that plane, guy.
Wait, there's somebody also sniping!
Oh shit!
Oh no.
Oh my god, he's also sniping.
I'm so low.
Wait, I'm not the only sniper.
Don't worry, I'm helping.
Don't worry, I'm helping!
Oh my god, he might kill me though.
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh no.
I'm okay.
It's fine, it's fine, I'm okay.
Oh shit!
I'm deploying drone!
Wait.
Oh my god.
Oh, I have to actually focus so much.
I'm- I actually have to focus!
Holy shit!
Jesus Christ, I actually have to think.
I actually have to think while playing this game.
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh!
Like I actually have to like...
Oh my god.
I can't like- Oh no!
No, no, no, no, no!
No!
He got- He neutralized me!
Oh, I can't- I can't like- I have to like think so much when I play here.
Holy fuck, I actually have to think so much though.
Like I'm- I'm trying so hard to focus concentrate.
Guys...
I have to be careful because I'm like super squishy too.
Okay.
Nice.
He's one.
Oh!
I think these are real people.
They play pretty smart.
Okay.
She's fun.
I like her.
I think I like this person- this character.
I definitely like her.
It's time to execute!
Ha ha ha ha!
No one's gonna stop me!
Ha ha ha!
That's right!
I execute that in front of all your teammates.
I don't know if that did anything.
Ooh!
It's fine.
Ha ha ha!
Wait.
Oh shit!
What did he do?
I don't know what that does.
Oh my god.
I don't know what he's doing.
Oh, I'm- Oh my god.
I'm so low.
I need one more.
He's so low.
Come on!
Ha ha!
He's so low!
Yes!
A new kill!
Okay.
That was fun.
I like Light Sniper.
I like, uh...
I don't think I got MVP.
But I got some cool ass- Yeah.
I-I don't think I got MVP, but- Oh, I did!
I did get MVP!
Let's go!
Fuck yeah!
I was goddamn dominating!
Ha ha ha!
That's right!
That was me!
Okay, I like- I like this character.
I like Narukami.
I think Narukami is really fun.
That's right.
It must be like really fun, cause she's on camo too, a lot.
Especially like, when you have all the drones out.
I think- Right now, I only tried three characters.
But, Narukami for me was definitely really fun.
I-I enjoyed it a lot.
Alright, I wanna try her.
I wanna try her in a...
5v5.
Uh...
Honestly- I-I-I-It was so fun!
I just love her movement.
Her movement- Uh...
Uh...
Her movement was crazy.
That's why- I-I don't know.
That's why I enjoyed it a lot.
Because her movement was- Uh...
Uh...
Was really crazy.
And her drones- Yeah, her drones can shoot through walls.
Which was like, you know, not fair.
Ha ha ha!
Like her- Her drones were- The fact that her drones can shoot through walls was crazy.
Because it's like, you know, as long- If I know where you are.
Uh...
If I know where- Yeah, if I know where you are, then like, you're fucked basically.
Tricera!
Ready to strike.
Okay.
Am I the only- Ready to strike.
Oh, I'm the only sniper.
Stego!
Ready to strike.
Yeah, I think her camo is still broken.
Not gonna lie.
Ready to strike.
A Focus Falcon counters her though, cause he can scan her.
Yeah, I feel like- If you know the enemy team has a- Narukami, you have to play something that can scan her.
Or like, it's just not gonna be fun at all.
Cause like, I- cause like, I assumed because I had so many of my drones out, that it was just really difficult to find me.
That's why I feel like she's so broken.
Oh, Narukami is the worst mecha, but she herself is so broken.
I feel like if you can- I feel like she's not good when you're playing against experienced players.
Because right now, a lot of people don't really know how to play against Narukami.
Narukami?
Because of how, um...
Um...
Because like, they're not used to playing against a stealth character.
But I think if I play against experienced players, people will counter her more.
Yeah, I just can't stay still.
I just have to like, move around a lot, in general.
Yeah, it's me!
Alright, I'll try- I'll try out Panther next.
Okay.
Come on.
Which one's me?
Yeah, just let me do everything I want.
Yeah, just let me do it.
Come on.
Oh shit!
Okay, nevermind.
Okay.
Oh, he's moving a lot.
Oh, this guy's moving so much.
I'll charge it up more.
Nice.
Okay, we got...
They're all like, heading over now.
Okay.
Aww.
Whoa.
Get out of here.
Okay, we gotta go to...
We gotta go to...
Get the...
Extractor.
Oh, come on.
He's so low.
Haha, that's right!
Alright.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm trying to like...
Run around a lot.
Like, move around a lot.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'll get him.
That's right!
I got my drone out!
That's fucking right!
I'm trying to move around a lot.
So they don't know which one's me.
Okay, nice.
What's that?
Haha, I don't know what I destroyed.
Don't worry, I'm helping.
Nice.
Don't worry, I'm deploying shit.
They don't know.
He he he.
I'm a little spider.
Guys, I think they know I'm here now.
They don't know.
Look at me.
I'm a little spider.
No, come on.
Just...
Come on!
Just move to the left!
A little bit!
Just a little bit to the left!
Please!
I'm stuck!
Okay, whatever.
Alright.
That's fine.
Wait, how did I score 21?
Wait, what?
Wait, I don't understand!
What happened?
Oh my god, I don't know how the point system works for this.
I don't know.
I should have helped.
I should have.
Whoops.
Please, where's my teammate?
Oh shit!
Okay, that's fine.
Where did my teammate go?
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
My teammates are not...
Oh, it's like capping!
Okay.
I'm dumb.
Alright, it's fine.
I need to grab, put my drone...
There we go.
I got a kill.
It's fine.
I don't have time to execute.
Okay, there's a guy right here though.
Okay.
Come on.
No more.
No, no, no, no!
He's won!
Come on!
Nice!
Okay, I wanted to kill this guy.
Can we get the objective?
Fuck!
There we go.
That should make him stagger, right?
Wait, how come he didn't get staggered?
It's staggered!
Oh my god.
Team, I need help!
Okay.
That's fine.
Bro, what the fuck is that?
Like, why does he do so much damage?
Jesus Christ, he does so much!
He's so tanky!
He does so much.
Holy fuck.
Okay, nice.
Nice, we got it.
I'm heading in, I'm heading in!
Okay, I want to try and get...
I think I got staggered there, but I'm not sure.
Oh!
Haha, you don't know which one's me!
Hahaha!
Oh shit!
I don't know.
I don't know which one's me, though.
Oh my god.
Oh shit, I didn't know what...
I didn't want to do that!
Fuck!
My...
Oh!
I have to move so much!
Please!
Oh no.
I'm so concerned.
Where's my team?
Hahaha!
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Get out!
Okay, I'm getting out.
Don't worry team!
I'm coming back!
I think!
Oh, why can't I see anything?
Am I dying?
I can't...
What's going on?
Am I dying?
I can't see anything!
Okay.
Ah!
I'm being spryed!
I can't see anything!
Who's me?
Which was my team?
I...
I can't tell!
Hahaha!
I couldn't tell who was my team and who wasn't!
Oh my god, he jumped.
Of course he did.
Hahaha!
Oh, he's so fucked.
He's so fucked, no.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Nice.
There we go, I staggered him.
Get him!
Get the panther!
Hahaha!
You can't tell!
That's right, you're so disoriented!
Hahaha!
I fucked around!
I actually fucked around!
Hahaha!
Yay!
Hey!
Okay.
Yeah, he can tell.
Yay!
Seven assists!
Holy shit!
Okay, I like her the most.
Alright, who do you guys want me to try next?
Yeah, I don't think I got MVP'd there.
Hahaha!
I mean, I got five kills!
She had two kills more than me, in the end.
Did I get anything?
Top Assault.
Wait, does that mean- Holy shit!
Bro, this- there's a guy, below me, that has like- that took a million damage.
Like, what- Wait, what does like, top Assault mean?
Does that mean I did the most damage?
Chat?
Is that what it means?
Is it that I did the most damage?
There's a guy that got taken a million damage, and he's like, the heavy brother.
Yeah.
Most damage- Yeah!
I did the most damage!
Let's go!
Yeah, that's me!
Okay, that's fun.
I like- I think- I not only tried three characters, but- the Nur- uh, the Nurkami guy is definitely my favorite so far.
Uh, but yeah, guys!
If you do exclamation point mecha, you can check out the game right now.
It is free to play.
And there's, um, twelve different classes that you can play right now on the launch day.
Yay!
Top damage!
That's me!
Alright.
Okay, I saw Panther and I saw Falcon.
Is there anything else you guys want me to try?
Also, we have drops!
So, um, if you watch my stream right now, you have a chance to get, uh, these- Okay, let me see.
These drops!
For free!
So, yeah!
And we have Twitch drops right now.
So, you guys really want to get some free cosmetics, just watch the stream!
Uh...
Am I, like, Panther's playstyle?
Okay, I'll try Panther.
Alright.
Oh, wait, that's not Panther.
Okay.
The brawler.
Okay, so he's the- He's a melee character, I remember.
So, I'll do- I'll try him in 3v3.
Is he good for 3v3 or nah?
Alright, let's try.
Falcon will suit me?
Okay, we'll try Falcon after this, too.
Alright.
Let's try Panther out and see what his abilities are.
Great mobility?
Okay.
Let's try it out.
I like the mobile characters.
I don't think you guys can tell from Nurikami.
I was, like, basically moving everywhere and it was, like, super disoriented.
Okay.
Lance.
Knocks back.
Dealing physical damage that pass-pies hold the charge.
Increases damage and thrust range.
Blocks all frontal attacks.
Shield regen stops when activated.
Parrys melee attacks and staggers the attacker within- Okay, so this parrys.
Shield blade.
Switches side-on to induce short, which bypasses dealing physical damage while staggering.
Performs an unparable downward slash when targeting low attitude.
Okay, so...
And then boot immediately and partially restores energy.
Three.
An additional shield that blocks attack from all damages.
Shield regen stops when activated.
Okay.
Useable during immobilization and stagger.
So I assume that's what he did.
Um...
Press to initiate a boost attack.
Okay, I assume that's what that guy did to me last time.
Okay.
So...
Let's try this out.
Okay.
Um...
Ooh!
Okay, so that's the charge.
And then...
Wait, where's the...
Wait, what's the other one?
One...
Okay.
Oh!
It was this.
It was the right click.
Okay.
That's what he did.
That was scary.
Oh, he charged lands me?
Okay.
Yeah, that shit was scary.
Okay, and then...
This is the shield where I can parry people, basically.
And then...
And then this is the shield regen.
And this is where I like block everybody.
Alright.
Emily restores energy and reinforce...
What's the cooldown for it?
Okay, the cooldown is not that bad.
Okay.
I have to be like...
I have to get super close though.
Into him.
Can I do this?
Can I charge this up?
When I'm flying?
Ooh...
Wait, I can charge this when I'm flying.
Wait, that's really good.
Oh, yeah.
You can charge this.
Have...
You press charge first.
And then you...
You can fly around with it.
Yeah, and then if I do that...
And I can get my energy back.
And then do that.
Yeah, okay.
So I can keep the juices going.
Yeah, and it doesn't waste...
Okay.
We'll try it.
Alright, let's try Panther out.
Let's try him 3-3.
Training complete.
So he's like basically a diver.
So like actual Panther, Panther.
That's why like I was like when...
I saw the name.
I was like, oh, Panther.
It has to be like a dive character.
Like why else...
Why the fuck else would it be named Panther?
I was like...
I don't know how to parry, guys.
That's why I play Sniper.
Guys...
You think I know how to...
I don't even parry...
In other games.
You think I know how to parry...
In this one?
Oh my god, there's Mega Man.
Oh my god.
What's he doing here?
Alright, I'm ready.
What's that?
Yeah, parry?
It is?
I don't know how the attacks...
To be fair, I don't know what the pattern attacks...
In this game yet.
Um...
Because like, you know, I just started playing.
So I don't know what the parry attacks actually look like.
Alright, here I go.
Woo!
Let's go, I'm ready.
Okay.
And then we'll try Falcon next.
What is Falcon's abilities?
Let's do this.
Like, what it...
What are they normally?
Okay.
What is this map?
Hello Mega Man.
Oh my god.
He's already shooting.
Don't worry, we got this.
We slowly move up.
Where's...
Are they just like...
The coward.
Holy shit.
Actual cowards.
Oh my god.
Wait, he par...
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
I was not expecting that from him.
Come on.
Oh ho ho ho.
Holy shit.
I was not expecting that.
Come on.
Get over here.
Oh my god.
What?
I got baited.
Oh my god.
I got baited so...
I got baited.
I'm so sad.
My teammates ran away!
Yay!
I swear I swapped to play.
I can't believe it.
My teammates ran away.
I'm so sad.
He was one!
Oh my god.
This is hard.
I'm not good at Panther.
I'm just not good at melee, I feel like.
I think melee is just difficult for me.
Are you serious?
Wait, what?
Wait, is that the parry?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm so bad at melee.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh my god.
What is going on?
Guys.
I think I found out.
I'm not meant to play.
I am definitely not meant to play.
Meant to play.
Melee.
I'm not meant to play.
I'm not good at it.
I am definitely not good at melee, guys.
Jesus Christ.
This is so dope.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
What?
Wait, where did he go?
What the fuck happened?
Oh, he had on?
I'm so confused.
That was so confusing.
Oh, I'm so fucking confused.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
These guys actually have a comp, too.
Like, I can't see people.
Is that my teammate or no?
How do I get out of Paul's arm?
Guys.
Oh my god.
There he is.
Jesus Christ!
Holy fuck, please!
No.
No way!
Oh, it's time-based?
Wait, is the game too loud, chat?
Wait, has the...
Has the...
It's like, uh...
Wait, has the game been too loud?
Oh, no?
Oh, okay.
Someone was like, the game is so loud.
Okay.
I don't like Panther.
I don't like him.
I'm not a Melee kid.
I think I found out...
That...
I'm not a Melee player.
I don't understand Melee.
I don't...
No, I definitely don't understand Melee.
How do I change?
I can change characters?
Yeah, I'm definitely...
What I noticed for me...
Is that I'm definitely...
Um...
I'm definitely a Melee...
Uh, uh...
Shooter.
Yeah, I've never been good at Melee characters.
I'm like, definitely...
I'm feeding so much too.
Which I feel bad.
I feel bad.
Oh my god!
I'm like...
I think my movement's good.
But...
I'm definitely like, not good at...
I'm definitely not good at...
Moving around.
Or like, uh...
I'm not good at...
Uh...
Using my Melee, in general.
My movement's good.
I think my movement's decent.
I'm just not good at...
Yeah.
Yeah, I think like, for me...
For me...
Um...
I definitely need to like...
Learn...
I think for me...
For...
Oh my god...
20...
What?
Oh, 20 kill...
Total kills.
For me...
It's definitely like...
You...
Panther seems to be like...
More...
More skill involved...
In terms of like...
Learning his mechanics.
But like...
As someone that...
Is not very good...
At Melee characters...
In general...
In any game...
Um...
He is...
So weird.
He is such a...
He's...
His playstyle is...
So hard...
To...
To figure out.
I'm just better at...
I'm better at movement...
Movement for...
Shooting.
Or movement shooters in general.
Is this movement or...
Aerial combat?
Alright.
What is this?
What are her abilities?
Alright.
Let's try her out.
But yeah.
Definitely no panther for me.
Panther was miserable.
Panther was...
So...
Miser...
Miserable to play.
Oh!
Is this a fighter jet?
Was this a fighter jet?
Where I kept like...
Um...
Where I just kept flying around?
Like where he just...
Yeah.
This is...
No, wait.
No, it wasn't.
Okay.
I thought this was the fly...
The flyer.
No.
He was actually...
In the actual plane when I saw him.
Okay.
Target required.
So he's like...
He seems to be doing post...
Damage.
Frecon...
Fires at locked targets.
Winged form.
Fires...
Dealing ballistic damage.
Winged form.
Heavy missiles.
He does.
Okay.
So...
Oh!
It is!
It is the playing guy.
Okay.
How do I...
But how do I use the...
The right click?
Oh no.
That's that.
Nevermind.
I'm...
JK.
I'm dumb.
Alright.
She seems really easy.
This is Tracer.
I assume she has to be like...
Super...
Fast.
Right?
Alright.
We'll try...
Is she good on arena?
Or is she bad on arena?
Guys.
Good or bad in arena chat.
Pretty bad?
Bad I'd say?
I'll...
I'll try the hero shooter mode then.
With her.
Maybe she'll be decent on hero shooters.
I have to stay in...
Just playing for him at all times?
Okay.
That's interesting.
Alright.
We'll try Falcon and then we'll go back to...
Uh...
Narukami.
Cause...
She's my boo.
She's my bae.
Oh my god.
That guy went from 11 deaths already.
Wait.
I don't wanna be...
They took Falcon.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
It's not fair!
WHAAAT?
Wait wait, see I told you.
You can literally swap.
That guy was fucking lying!
I told you guys.
I told you guys he was lying.
I guess...
Narukami.
I guess we play Narukami.
Back to Narukami.
If I wanted to play her in here, I wanna play Narukami in 3v3.
I think 3v3v3...
It's more...
It's more, um...
What's the word?
Um, it's more skill-based.
Alright, here I go.
Alright, after this, we'll try...
We'll try...
Uh...
We'll actually try a falcon.
Narukami!
I'm coming down!
Beep beep!
I like how I'm trying different maps every time, though.
I like that.
I thought my drone, like, literally fell down.
Wait, did he die already?
Wait, where is he?
Wouldn't it be funny if he actually died there?
Where is he?
Holy shit.
Oh my god, they're all flying.
Everybody...
Oh, everybody...
People are starting to outplay this game now.
Come on!
Hey!
Goodbye!
I don't think he knows.
He's like, who's hitting me?
Ah, shit!
Okay.
He doesn't know.
I can just stay up here.
Where am I?
Oh, shit!
They're not letting me have fun!
Hehehe.
Oh, shit!
Whoa!
Hey, buddy!
Chill, buddy!
Chill!
Let me kill one of your teammates!
Okay, I should actually do the objective.
I can't help it.
Is he dead?
No.
Oh, he got a whip!
Wait, he actually got a whip!
Oh, nice.
Never mind.
Okay, we got him.
I have to figure out how to get up.
How do you get up, guys?
How did you guys...
Oh, shit!
What are you doing down here?
Oh, there you go.
Guys, we got captured!
We got to do objectives, guys!
Nice.
We did it.
We're doing objectives.
They don't know that.
They don't know where I am.
He, he, he.
He thought he was safe!
Haha, jokes on him!
Okay, we got to help this guy though.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's fine.
I'm okay with that.
I love... I don't... I... Oh.
Oh, he just dodged it.
God, I love this character.
He's so fun.
I'm glad people don't know how to play this character.
I'm glad I play against this character.
Wait, what?
What's been captured?
Oh, we have the...
Oh, that's captured by enemy.
Oh, shit.
Unlucky.
I'll use the shield now.
I don't think he knows.
He he he, I'm a spider.
Come on, get out of here.
Did I miss?
Oh, yeah.
I'm glad I'm not.
I would be so mad too.
Look in here.
The sky is ours.
We wonder if it's... Oh, we have to go here.
Help him.
Oh, shit.
What's hitting me?
Oh, no.
I don't think he knows.
I'll kill him first.
No, I need to kill him before I die.
I need to kill him.
No!
Wait, he has shields!
I fucking fucked up!
Okay.
It's fine.
Ready to provide aerial cover.
I'm helping.
No way, I got you!
No!
Who hit me?
Who is this guy?
Oh, my God.
He's also sniping.
It's also a Nurukami.
Oh!
It was also... They have a sniper too.
I didn't even see him.
Oh, my God.
This guy was also sniping.
They're winning.
Wait, how did they get the objective so... Oh, my God.
How?
We gotta capture it.
Holy shit.
Oh, he's so low.
Oh, then he knows.
Oh, he does!
He does.
Holy fuck.
Oh, they're winning.
Yeah, they capped everything.
Oh, no!
The panther got me!
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
The Falcon has a thing on.
No!
My team isn't playing objective anymore!
Please, team!
Why aren't you guys...
What happened?
Oh, wait.
I'm top fragger.
Okay, that's what happened.
My team.
Bro, this guy's 6...
Oh, my God.
He has 600...
Bro, I have a guy with 6k damage.
Okay, what is that guy with 6k damage doing?
What is he doing?
He has 6k.
He has 6k damage.
Fight the team!
Team!
Okay.
I need like...
Oh, my gosh.
The issue for me is that...
I'm not paying attention to like...
I truly feel pity for you.
Oh, no!
No, don't say that.
It's fucked up.
Please, I'm trying my best here.
Okay, what hasn't been...
What can you capture?
Don't say that.
Okay.
Where's B?
Okay, B is over there.
Oh, my God.
I'm the first one.
I'm the first one to actually press the objective.
Oh, that guy is a fucking nerd.
That's a natural nerd.
Holy shit.
Alright, there we go.
Okay, this guy will die.
I was gonna say, this guy's gonna have to die.
Alright, we got it.
Okay.
I'm trying to help my team.
Energy.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I have to kill this guy.
Nice, I got him.
We gotta get C though.
Oh!
Coming over, Pathy!
I'm here to help!
Nice!
Oh God, we have to go back to- God damn it!
We have to go back to B?
Oh, I don't like this mode.
This mode is too fucking long.
I'm gonna say it.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
We're fine for now.
We got, we got B.
I don't like this.
Oh, thank God we got it.
A thousand.
Oh, this.
Victory!
That mode was so long.
I'm using grapple more so for emergency, to be fair.
I'm doing it more so for like, emergency's sake.
Nice.
Okay.
We did it.
I don't know.
I'm definitely not MVP.
That, that shit was like, a lot.
Holy, oh wait.
Four deaths?
Okay, I was gonna- Okay, 7-1-1.
Okay.
32 total kills.
I don't even know how much I got.
How much did I get?
Okay, no.
I was almost there.
I was, I just had one extra death.
Okay, so I was 7-2-2.
So I was, I was, I was helping.
I had two assists in.
I literally just needed, I was, I was just like, one, uh...
One, uh, one kill off.
Wait, I don't even get a card?
What the fuck?
I don't...
I don't even get a...
I don't even get a card?
I...
What did I do?
I can't...
Okay, let me check.
200, okay.
This guy was...
Oh, cause he got some pills.
He had...
He took...
861k.
I mean, I took the least amount of damage!
Come on!
Come fucking on!
Like, this guy did 7k!
That...
Oh, yeah.
That was bullshit.
I can't believe it.
You won no participation trophy.
Okay, now I can play Falcon.
Okay, now...
I'll try a Falcon.
Alright, here we go.
I wanna try...
I wanna do 3v3, but like...
Falcon apparently is really badass at 3v3.
So we'll try again on Hero.
And see if we can get Falcon again.
Let's see...
Oh, are we all fighting?
No, none of...
Nobody wants to...
Okay.
Yeah!
Ready to strike.
That's right, bitch.
I Falcon now.
Ready to strike.
Stellaris.
We're all ready to strike, guys.
That's right.
We're ready to strike.
No, I was laughing at the guy that did 7k...
7k fucking damage.
Alright, here we go.
There are filters for modes?
Oh, that's really good.
I like that.
I like that you can filter...
Uh...
You can filter out like ones you don't like.
Because I definitely didn't like the Domination one.
That one...
So long.
I took way too long.
Yeah, this game is free to play.
And then...
And you can select 12...
There's 12 different...
Characters you can select on launch day.
Which is right now.
Dennis, it's who you're mortal.
Also than turns!
Thank you for the tier one.
Said you thank you.
Trance, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Uh...
Thank you...
For the Twitch Prime.
And also...
Crack , thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Falcon here...
All right.
This one.
I feel like.
I'm gonna be a little more confused.
Okay, I assume I have to be always on playing mode.
Oh my god.
So I assume I have to always, like, run around.
How the fuck do I do anything?
Bro, I literally, I'm just flying.
Whee!
Oh, okay, now I don't have... Okay.
Oh, shit, I have to... I have to back off.
I have to, like...
Nice, alright.
Alright.
Yo Shaybari, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay, I need to recharge.
For sure.
Okay.
I, I just think I'm just poking people...
I... I'm literally just...
I'm just a player.
Weeeeeee!
Bro,
no body can't hit me, I'm so fast.
I'm actually so fast.
Nice.
Okay, this is sad.
This is actually sad for the enemy team.
Pew pew pew pew pew 85 lusts.
Yeah, I'm remembering to shoot three.
Don't worry, I definitely remembered to shoot three.
Okay, I'm gonna kill this guy.
This guy seems to be the saddest one.
This guy doesn't seem to have fingers.
Oh that's so sad.
Who's that shooting me right now?
I fly.
Okay, okay, we gotta drop down though.
Oh shit!
That's the whole team!
Alright, we leave.
Did we win?
It's like bullying!
I'm literally just flying!
I'm just doing... I'm just shooting everywhere.
Oh my god!
That's so bullshit!
But this poor guy had 300 ping, I saw.
Okay, there's another round.
Okay.
No, apparently it's two rounds.
Whoever gets two rounds.
Like, that map was not fair.
Oh shit!
Oh I think they know!
I think they know where I am now!
Whoa!
What?
I think they know!
I think they're trying to shoot me a specific... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Wow!
Everyone's turn to shoot me!
Holy fuck!
Okay, they definitely knew now.
They knew who to shoot this time!
Oh my god!
Yeah, I definitely got shot by everything possible!
Bro, stop!
Stop, buddy!
Stop!
Woo!
Oh my god!
What's wrong with that!
Don't fly into this!
But they're just like staying there!
It's so hard not to!
They're literally just staying there!
Okay, I'll help him!
Okay, we gotta go to the repair though!
Okay, I need to repair myself!
It's okay!
We're fine!
They learned!
They actually learned this time!
Yeah, they learned!
They're...
It's fine!
Let's keep healing!
I believe in my team!
Alright, there you go!
I'll help now!
Alright, let's get back downstairs!
Yay!
I have to have like a shitload of assists right now!
But it is pretty dumb!
I'm gonna say that!
Falcon... Falcon seems to be really, really good at air maps!
For sure!
I like...
I...
Falcon... I'm just... I'm literally just...
I'm just... I'm just...
I have 9 assists!
Holy fuck!
I have... I have... I have... I have 9... I have 9 assists!
And only 1 kill!
I was literally just in there, zooming around!
I'm just... just flying around and being a nuisance!
Still wanna save the day!
Sounds about right!
Wait, I wanna know!
How many kills everyone get?
Okay, 1... Okay, yeah, this guy...
Okay... Wait, this guy didn't even win?!
I mean... I was the only one...
Okay, this guy got assists too!
But I...
I don't even know what I was doing!
I...
I don't know what I was doing!
I'm gonna be honest with you guys!
I...
I was...
I was like...
Nooo...
Weeeee!
Alright, I'll do one more!
Guys, I'll do one more!
I wanna do 3v3!
I really like 3v3!
And we know what we're gonna play on 3v3!
Hee hee!
Okay, wait...
Uh...
We gotta swap our striker first...
Before...
We know what we wanna play!
Okay, I might get absolute shit on though!
Cause I think like...
People are getting better!
Yeah!
She's so dumb!
Okay!
I think Falcon is...
Falcon is pretty dumb to play!
I have to bet...
Falcon was like the character where I was like...
Head empty!
And just...
I'm free!
I'm...
I'm a free bird!
Hehehehe!
Matthew, thank you for gifting a...
Sub!
To Kirby, thank you!
Thank you!
Alright...
Ready to strike!
Narukami!
Okay, who...
Oh, I was gonna say...
Back to thinking!
Yeah...
It's time to think again!
Okay, but yeah...
Um...
If you guys wanna...
If you guys wanna check out the game...
Right now...
It is free to play!
So do exclamation point mecha!
And you can...
Download the game right now with my link!
What if...
3v3 falcon game mode!
Wait!
Can we make custom room right now?
Okay!
We're ending it with a 3v3 falcon!
You're gonna...
Wait, I wanna end it on...
3v3 falcon game mode!
Alright...
That sounds so dumb!
But so fun at the same time!
Wait!
There's a falcon!
There's a falcon right there!
Okay...
Where is he?
There he is!
What are you doing?
Oh shit!
I'm so dumb!
What
is...
What is...
Wait!
No!
Wait, I got him!
I got him!
Nice!
Okay!
That map fucking sucked!
That map...
That map was crazy!
Okay!
I...
Found the map I hate the most!
For sure!
I definitely know what map I hate!
Oh...
Fuck this!
Oh shit!
Fuck me!
He's fading me!
Ah!
That dashed into it!
I hate the environmental damage!
I...
I wanted to kill him!
I hate the environmental damage!
I...
I got greedy!
I really wanted to kill him!
No, you guys don't understand!
I hate...
Oh, he knows!
He's using the scouter!
Oh, they know!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
I hate...
There we go!
Okay!
I gotta be careful with this!
God!
Okay!
I see it!
I see the engine!
Okay!
Nice!
Oh my god!
Come on!
It's fine!
I'm...
I'm okay with thinking for this one!
Nice!
We got assist!
Oh, I see you!
Come on!
I see you!
Peek me!
Come on!
You're so dumb!
Literally, the only reason I died was that goddamn engine room!
I try...
I have to look at the engine beam because I can't...
Oh, look at that!
Six kills!
That's just sad!
I better get MVP!
I got six kills out of that eight!
My one death was literally because I flew into the fucking engine room!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
That's so dumb!
I can't...
Okay!
I better...
I better carry this team!
Holy fuck!
I was playing out of my mind there!
Alright!
Oh, this guy was a natural baby!
Fizz...
Jeez!
He has...
Seven...
He's been playing for point...
Okay!
I was gonna say...
He has a hundred percent...
Oh!
He doesn't have a win rate on this!
So...
Get out of my lobby!
That's so cute!
Yeah, alright!
Guys, okay!
I know I said last game with...
Fal...
Uh, with...
With now...
But I...
Okay!
How do we do custom lobbies?
I want...
A 3V3...
Custom...
Oh, custom room!
There we go!
3V3...
Custom...
Lobby!
Falcon only.
Wait, which maps should we do?
Wait.
Which one is the best map?
Okay, obviously, it has to be Operation Merge.
Okay.
Wait, no, it has to be Ace Arena because it's 3v3.
I don't think six of us.
I don't think we should do six of us in.
All right.
Which is... is this?
Oh, this is Ariel.
Okay.
Guys.
Falcon only.
Falcon only, guys.
It has to be Falcon only.
Guys.
Not... Guys, come in here.
We're ending it with... 3v3 Falcon only.
All right.
Let's go.
I swear to God, we better all be... we better all be Falcons, guys.
It's even better.
All right.
Ready to strike.
Oh, can we not do that?
Oh, nice.
We can.
Oh, can we not lock in?
Oh, we can.
Okay.
Ready to strike.
All Falcon.
No, we don't.
We don't have to.
We can actually be all Falcons.
All right.
Let's go.
It's going to be so dumb.
It's going to be so fucking stupid.
But...
It's Falcon time.
Falcons roll out.
I don't know how we are going to die.
My falcon team.
Alright, here we go.
The fight of the mosquitos.
Launch!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go, guys.
The sky is ours, guys.
Oh my god!
Oh my shields!
Wait, this guy is almost dead!
This guy... No!
Oh no, I have to recharge.
Guys, I have to recharge!
No!
Oh my god.
Okay, I got first kill though.
I missed you down.
Don't worry, I'm back!
Don't worry, I'm here!
Don't worry, team!
Don't worry!
The falcon's here too!
Oh my god!
That's right, I'm coming for you.
Wait, somebody... Wait, no, nobody... I just can't see.
Okay.
Don't worry, I got you.
It's okay.
Somebody... Oh my god!
Somebody has... One of my teammates has 500 ping!
I don't know what your plan is, guys.
It's okay, but nobody's dying!
Nobody... Nobody is dying!
Because... Okay.
Because we're all just in the sky...
It's so hard to kill anybody.
Okay, it's fine.
There we go.
That's right.
I'm in your walls.
Okay, I'm gonna recharge.
I'm gonna recharge energy.
Okay.
We gotta help him.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I got you, Falcons.
Don't worry.
Oh my god, this fight is so close.
This is so close already.
Okay.
We gotta get this guy.
Don't worry.
I know how to manage my fuel now.
I'm learning.
Where are the other planes?
There we go.
Look at this aerial maneuver.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
Oh my god, I see you.
I fucking see you.
Oh shit, I'm out.
I'm out of range.
Oh my god, I'm so lost.
Where am I?
Stabilizing.
Oh, where?
Oh, it's the pulse door.
Oh no.
We can't see.
We got high.
Oh my god.
Teammate.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I got you, team.
I can't see anything, but I got you.
Oh my god, we can't aim because I can't see.
I don't know which one.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, I see you.
There you go.
Oh no, not the posture.
Oh my god.
Oh, I see you.
Oh, I know you're... Where are you?
Wait, where are you?
I have a... No, my compass doesn't work.
What do you mean are advancing?
Oh my god, he killed two.
Oh no, compass jams.
Oh no, my compass jams.
I don't know.
Oh shit, I think they knew.
Guys, team, team, team, team, I need help.
Team, I need help.
Okay,
we still have... Okay, it's five, it's five.
You don't know what's happening?
Don't worry.
I don't think any of us do.
I literally don't think any of us know what we're doing right now.
The sky is ours.
It's so hard to play the... to play out the Falcon.
Holy shit.
Holy fuck.
Where's my teammate?
Oh no.
We have to leave.
Team!
I'm getting jumped!
Where's my team?
Oh no.
Oh, I wasn't!
Okay, that's good.
It wasn't me.
I wasn't last killed.
Yay!
Guys, it's okay.
I wasn't last killed.
It's okay.
I'm being overstimulated.
It's great.
That's all that matters.
We did it, guys.
Oh, that's a cool design.
That design was cool.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
That was a crazy Falcon.
Falcon V Falcon game.
All right.
That... that was really fun, though.
Again...
Hey...
I can't believe...
I can't believe you can do all Falcons.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can do custom paint and everything.
You can...
Summonize so much stuff for this game.
But again, a huge shout out and thank you to Amazing Season Games for the sponsor.
And, um...
For inviting me to check out this game.
As you guys know, this is free to play.
So, um...
So, you don't have to pay anything.
And the game already comes out with like 12 characters that you can play on launch.
So, there's a lot of different types of characters you can play.
You can do Melee.
You can do Sniper.
You can do whatever the fuck I just did.
With the pea shooter in the air.
Like I said, my favorite is definitely Nurukami as a sniper.
I think her sniping and movement sniping is really, really fun for me out of all the characters.
But obviously, it depends on like what type of play style you like.
And I like movement shooters.
So, it's actually crazy.
I didn't even play a single support.
I feel like for this game because like...
I don't know.
I guess if it's ranked, then I'd play support.
But like, for this game right now, at the moment, there's no reason to play support.
Because it's like, you know...
Because you're mostly just shooting.
So, I feel like...
I think if it was ranked, then maybe.
But for quick play, I don't think you really need support at all.
But yes, for those who don't know, this is a third person shooter.
The only thing I didn't try out as much was MASHMACK.
But that was because I personally am not like a huge fan of extraction shooters in general.
But that's why...
That's why...
There's three different modes that you can do for whichever...
You know, for the specific type of game mode that you like to do.
So, for me in general, I like Kyo Shooter and I like 3v3.
So, they were really fun for me.
Extraction shooter in general, I just...
I'm not like a huge extraction shooter guy.
That's why I only played it once.
Omni, thank you for 1000Bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
And Ranul-san, thank you for the resub.
I don't know if there is already ranked, but...
I won't be surprised if it's added later on.
But yes, as you can see, you can customize your mechas and everything.
You can customize your character and you can customize your mechas as well.
And it's available on Steam, Xbox, and Windows PC via the Xbox app.
But yes, thank you again, everybody.
I hope you guys had a fun time.
I hope you guys got your Twitch drops.
For those who don't know, you get Twitch drops for watching.
So, I hope all of you guys were able to get some Twitch drops.
Do not worry if you guys didn't because I will be streaming this again.
I am sponsored to stream this again, I believe, next week.
So, I will be streaming again next week for everybody.
So, if you guys did not get your drops, next week I will be streaming again for those who haven't got it yet.
But yes, thank you again to Mecha Break and Amazing CSUN Games for the sponsor.
I'm going to call it here.
As always, everybody, say hi.
Oh wait, before I leave, for those who don't know me, my name is DokiBrain.
I usually stream on YouTube, but today I'm on Twitch for the sponsor.
Because, you know, like I said, Twitch drops.
I did have a lot of fun.
But yes, you can check me out on YouTube.
Please feel free to subscribe to me over there.
If you guys want to support the stream, support the sponsor, please feel free to do exclamation point Mecha and click on the link that's pinned in the chat or that's in the command.
So, it does support the stream and it does support the sponsor.
And it's free.
The game is free.
You can download it via the link.
If you want to support me via other means, there are other things going on.
If you use the commands merch or Hyatt or Gamersupps, there's other means to support me.
What else?
What else do I have to share?
Oh, yes.
If you're going to be at Anime Expo on July 3rd, I will be having a 3D concert at Anime Expo.
And I will have like merch there as well.
So, you guys can purchase some stuff over there.
I'm trying to see if there's anything else to ship.
If you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch, follow me on Twitter.
So, follow me on Twitter, the exclamation point socials.
I usually tweet out whenever I stream on Twitch.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated, pause your check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you suffer me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.